there's a boring sameness to brand
marketing and most advertising
brands want to remind you they exist
give you some positive association with
their brand and leave you hopefully
with the laugh or at most keep you from
being annoyed that they are the 100th ad
that you're seeing that day but that
last part
the fact that you've seen so many ads is
a major problem for brands and today
in marketing monday we're going to talk
about how some brands have cut through
the noise and in particular how i think
one brand changed advertising
forever but let's just be clear the
problem that many brands are facing is
not that their ads aren't well
structured not that the creative
isn't there but quite simply it's the
volume of advertisements
that customers face every day they're
just among a sea of other
highly polished celebrity endorsed
products
so if you're a brand particularly a
brand of a boring product like
laundry detergent how do you deal with
that how do you cut through the noise
enter super bowl 52 first quarter
the ads come on you're about to see some
marketing magic
yeah just your typical super bowl car ad
right or a hilarious beer ad
or whatever ad this is whatever
but it's a tie dad in the literal
super bowl of advertising tide throws us
a curveball they take a big risk with
some meta advertising
they don't want to just be any ad they
want to be
every ad what it's a tie dad what makes
it a tie down there are no stains
look at those clean clothes what else
would this be an ad for
diamonds a gift that lasts for a no
time it's time for a cold reflection
try that now already the idea
is killer right it's a laundry detergent
and they know
every single ad is gonna have hyper
polished perfectly clean clothes
right but what makes it better is the
strategic
placement of it i would say probably
helped by sachi and sachi
which is that they placed this at the
first quarter of the super bowl meaning
all the commercials were in front of it
but that's not all
if they had stopped there they'd be
considered an all-time great ad
but they went further they're playing on
your expectations that you're gonna see
a beer at a car ad an insurance ad so
rather than just stop there
they keep playing the game they got
several
other super bowl spots strategically
placed throughout
the super bowl to keep you guessing to
keep the audience playing the game and
remembering
that maybe this is a tight ad fall into
and not only do they create ads they use
some of the most memorable characters
from advertising you know and already
love to create
a positive brand association with tide
it's insane
hello again ladies is your man the kind
of man who would climb the height
hmm i'm in a tight head
nice pants get off my horse
that's absolutely brilliant
beautiful like a tiger
at every point they are playing with the
audience they're subverting your
expectations
this follow-through is what takes meta
advertising from
maybe a cheap trick to something that
literally becomes one of the most
memorable super bowl commercials
of all time
sarah sarah it's a tie down
it's just genius and you know i want to
answer something
that maybe i don't talk about so much in
my videos which is okay it's a great ad
does that convert to sales and to answer
this
i'm gonna listen to mark ritzen instead
of myself he's much smarter than i am
the the size and strength for the brand
15
and context where it was placed 2
but with a whopping 47 the most
important factor at least according to
nielsen in gaining new market
effectiveness
is very simple the quality of the
creative
execution at the heart of your
advertising this is kind of obvious
right but it's also
important to remember look tide is an
old brand
that's positive because they have a huge
market share but it's also
just this thing that everyone feels like
they know so companies like that are
constantly looking to reinvent
themselves to recapture the imagination
and
hopefully more of the market share of
their audience this is why companies
spend
so much in order to get on the super
bowl
it's a unique opportunity to tell a
story that
well to be honest your audience is
actually going to listen to
what other commercial do you know that
people
willingly watch than the super bowl
there's not many but the super bowl sets
you
up to deliver your best advertising and
in this case
tide actually brought it here's mark
ritzen again reminding us
of why it's so important to be creative
with your advertising
creativity isn't just important for the
sake of it it's important because it has
as you can see here
a massive impact on the efficiency of
how well your money
works for your brand ladies and
gentlemen the purpose of marketing
mondays
is not merely to just look at great
advertising for the sake of it
but to make a point to deliver a point
you can reinvent
seemingly banal products with new life
you can reinvigorate them
all with the power of great marketing i
know on this channel we so
often rip on sleazeback marketers who go
too far with their advertising and
promise too much while delivering too
little
but the truth about marketing is that it
really is a
superpower when done right when done
right you can take
an ordinary laundry detergent and make
it the talk of the town
so yeah i hope you enjoy that i hope it
made you appreciate
the brilliance of this ad a little bit
more in fact the several ads
that they followed up with because i do
believe that that's what really gave
this
such power and um yeah let me know what
you want to see
next in marketing mondays i'm just so
glad we can celebrate
such incredible creative people and
thanks for watching
i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
you